[Musique]
il
annick bouquay bonjour bonjour merci
d'être présente sur le plateau de tv
soixante dix huit pour ce vip qui vous
est entièrement consacré vous êtes ici
en tant que versaillaise en tant que
président d'une association qui
s'appelle dites moi comment s'appelle
votre association association de
nouvelles du vivre ensemble aussi à vous
remercier de consacrer votre temps pour
je puisse pas communiquer communiquer
lentement on va parler parce que rose
d'un événement qui va avoir lieu donc le
11 mai
samedi et qui s'appelle les olympiades
du vivre ensemble et qui fait c'est sa
dixième édition dixième édition
voilà donc il ya plein de choses à
raconter sur cet événement sur toute
l'association en général déjà vous même
vous êtes versaillaise crois que vous
avez eu plus le métier vous avez déjà
été infirmière j'ai commencé par être
infirmière voilà après j'ai passé le
concours pour être professeur des écoles
vous avez exercé comme professeur des
écoles oui j'ai exercé aux mureaux j'ai
exercé à bezons effet après petit à
petit je me suis rapproché j'ai exercé
au chesnay j'en oublie peut-être pas
grave c'est pas grave
et pour finir à versailles d'accord et
il se trouve que vous avez donc vous
êtes occupé d'un événement qui avait
lieu donc on l'a dit depuis dix ans les
olympiens du vivre ensemble
comment on peut le qualifier cet
événement alors ces vastes ah oui c'est
très valable après alizé est un vrai
beau ils vont en fait c'est un
enfin disons que sa part de quelques
postulats c'est quoi l'idée le postulat
c'est que je suis convaincu que grâce au
non valide
on va réapprendre les bases y vivre
ensemble cazaux handicap est exactement
sur les choses voilà et puis parce que
quand on est face à une personne en
difficulté par exemple en fauteuil ou
malvoyantes étourdi tiens on va aller
l'aider on va aller vers la personne on
va comprendre son handicap parce que
comme je dis si les sourcils et en
fauteuil ou avec des béquilles bas on
doit pas se comporter la même façon donc
on va comprendre son handicap donc on va
oublier un petit peu comment fonctionne
pour se mettre vraiment dans cette
personne puis on va l'accompagner quand
on va l'accompagner on va accompagner en
fonction de son rythme il n'est pas
question d'aller à son propre corps et
cavaliers
et puis pendant ce trajet on se rend
compte que c'est une personne comme une
autre avec sa richesse
quel que soit son apparence est très
souvent quand on a fini selon va dire ce
qu'on pensait être une bea
eh ben on va avoir le sentiment d'être
de fierté de joie et d'avoir fait
quelque chose de deux pièces de vins
vraiment est fier de soi de valoriser en
dévalorisant
oui mais finalement c'est quelque chose
qui apporte à la personne qui a pas aux
deux personnes hautement finalement
c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs que la
thématique de ma journée c'est donner
recevoir partager d'accord donc c'est
une journée une seule qui a lieu donc
une fois par an c'est donc à versailles
autour du stade mont boron
voilà on utilise tout voler tout le
complexe c'est à dire à la fois la piste
d'athlétisme les les deux gymnases la
piscine vers marine ou près sa piscine
jusqu'à 13 heures et ils nous prêtent
aussi toute la journée les un espace
vert près du solarium et enfin voilà on
utilise tout le complexe sportif il y a
j'irai pas une course mais un parcours
qui se fait aussi en ville qui va
jusqu'au château et qui remonte vers le
complexe sportif avec des joëlettes et
je sais ce que c'est qu'une joël aide
pour ceux qui se sont alors c est à une
roue je pourrais l'assimilé je sais plus
comment à laon transport des personnes
handicapées
et puis ce sont des coûts des coureurs
qui se relaient pour faire découvrir
alors soit dire on en voit à l'écran
voilà exactement c'est tout à coup ça et
alors on fait participer ses jeunes
enfants handicapés ou même des jeunes
adultes à des courses 6e et mêmes
coureurs comme on dit au site pilote et
puis nous on est mais voilà ces données
les gens exactement
et puis en plus ça fédère énormément
pour les coureurs parce que c'est pareil
il faut s'adapter aux autres coureurs il
n'est pas question d'aller plus vite
qu'un autre on vit tous au rythme des
uns des autres et puis on oublie parfois
nous fatigue quand on fait des longues
courses
parce que le but ça doit être un moment
de joie et de fête pour l'enfant pour le
pour la personne handicapée
donc en fait ça nous surpasse en fait et
très souvent les autres coureurs aussi
qui nous accompagnent voix de seth
joëlette ça fédère ça fait un moment
vraiment de de bonne humeur et bidonné
de cohésion d'une union vise avant tout
vers un même but et puis on arrive
surtout tous ensemble d'accords est
important ouais alors dites moi comment
ça s'organise vous avez donc des
invalides qui sont inscrits je crois que
jusqu'à présent une plus de 6 ans
exactement il y en a là aussi sans
qu'ils aient lente la région dans toute
l'île 9 sens et c'est tout type de
handicap que ce soit un handicap
physique et piles handicap montagne
handicap sensoriel
d'accord on peut encore s'inscrire si
même jour même le jour même tout le
monde est accueilli et bienvenue
d'accord et les noms et les valide donc
ne s'inscrivent pas et viennent le jour
même c'est ça exactement
voilà on sait qu'on a des des classes de
lycée qui vont venir
c'est ce que j'allais vous dire vous
avez certes un partenariat avec des
aides aux associations par exemple
laquelle sont elles alors qu'elles sont
nées au cjc valides qui viennent alors
participer alors oui dans les valides on
a les bénévoles qui
qui sont soit les ateliers sportifs way
qui est parce que en fait on a 25
ateliers sportifs
donc ça veut dire 25 sports différents
vingt-cinq sport différent de 25
associations de 25 associations
différentes différents d'accord de daisy
blineau autres et donc ils arrivent avec
leur quota de binza parce que chacun
fait son atelier comme il l'entend et
avec le fin le nombre de bénévoles
qu'ils ont besoin
et puis des valides ce sont des lycéens
parfois des élèves aussi de la de
faculté et puis nous avons aussi des
jeunes du routard ac
et puis nous avons des scouts et nous
avons des jeunes de la pjj avec laura
qu'est ce que c'est que la bbc la
protection judiciaire protection des
jeunes de judiciaire c'est à dire que ce
sont des jeunes qui sont suivis par des
éducateurs ont eu un parcours peut être
un peu compliqué et voilà ils viennent
depuis deux trois ans à cette journée
ils se donnent pleinement
ils font à la fois la sécurité à la fois
ils apportent de l'eau est à la fois ils
participent aux ateliers sportifs avec
les personnes en situation de handicap
vous avez aussi des jeunes qui sont
placés en foyer exactement nous avons
des jeunes placés en foyers qui sont
assez nombreux et puis aussi en avant
des jeunes qui viennent du val fourré et
de trappes
on va fort et une qui viennent de
l'association de nuit à pic
qu'est ce que c'est une association qui
au coeur du val fourré qui fait un
travail extraordinaire qui s'occupe de
plus de 500 jeunes qui fait du soutien
scolaire de l'accompagnement de la
réinsertion d'accord que ceux qui ont
vite veniez les a et les emmène
exactement le 11 mai alors c'est assez
rigolo enfin rigolo on va des scouts
hors auto jeunes du rotary aux jeunes du
val fourré fin c'est un vrai melting
potes c'est un gars génial j'imagine c
est ben ben ali non valide toutes les
classes sociales tous les milieux alger
tous et que dans le même but dans le
même but hier qu' on ne vient se met un
panneau dans le dos et on déjà pas le
panneau qui dans le langage ou de
l'autre et on partage cette journée une
bonne humeur c'est vrai que le sport
c'est un moment
c'est accessible à tous c'est simple on
quel que soit son niveau ça n'a pas
d'importance
y a pas de compétition juste c'est le
plaisir de découvrir certaines activités
c'est le plaisir de participer ensemble
de faire les choses ensemble
c'est très important et puis surtout sa
permission sportive de réaliser qu'ils
peuvent intégrer des personnes non
valides dans leurs ressources pour ce
qui passe parce qu'ils ne font pas non
tout le font pas parce que parce
qu'elles ne savent pas qu'elles peuvent
avoir ces compétences que c'est possible
ça peut ouvrir des ddd possible
justement ces associations c'est dur bah
tiens pourquoi pas c'est que se crée une
section est invalide c'est ce qui se
passe avec maya cette association depuis
les olympiens qui qui ont ouvert section
justement les sections de non valide
et puis ça permet aussi aux personnes
non valides de pouvoir faire du sport
pour être proche de chez eux
j'ai renoncé très compliqué et souvent
ben y'a réalisation oui pardon je vous
coupe mais les associations qui ont
ouvert une section ono valide sait
quelles sont elles alors il ya le basket
ouais c'est que ces quatre bouteilles
non le basket de versailles le chesnay
là on tente le chesnay-versailles way
qui ont ouvert d'abord une section de
sport adapté d'accord goodkap mandanne
et qui ouvre à la rentrée une section de
basket fauteuil alors elle a un peu ils
font carrément dans les deux domaines
alors souvent cdc des sections un peu à
part il n'y a pas de mélange mais par
contre les personnes en même maillot
parts appartiennent au même club ce
n'est pas rien et quand il ya des
compétitions
s'il sait bien aussi que quand tu es une
compétition de valides que soit en avant
soit à la mi temps
il est libre à l'étagé après les
présentations des réalités ou de sport
photo à la jarne le programme de cette
journée donc du 11 mai qui extrêmement
riche
qui a des sports un peu bizarre il ya le
chambard à le showdown le kin ball
on va prendre juste le chambard à parce
qu'on a plus beaucoup de temps qu'est ce
que c'est alors le champ barras et c'est
un sport qui était connu qui est un peu
analogue masia voilà c'est un sport
d'art martial cds pp avec de la mousse
et c'est vraiment adapté à tout type de
handicap mais c'est aussi un sport de
valide un bon hockey et le jeune homme
jeudi justin bieber est bon pour
malvoyants d'accord les étapes pour
malvoyants donc rien même pour pour
aller voir tout ce qui existe et ce
sourire plein de possibles au niveau du
sport qu'on soit valide ou invalide déjà
ça vaut le coup passer une journée comme
vous dites de bonne humeur et de dia
vous avez des champions aussi
paralympiques qui viennent alors cette
année on a quinze champions car un pic
et paralympiques d'accord il sert comme
les sons sportive ya autant de ce sont
valides et non valides pareil pour les
sportifs c'est très important et ils
viennent de toute une journée pour se
donner pleinement à animer les ateliers
de leur spécialité et ça se fait
toujours en toute simplicité vraiment on
y va parce qu'on en a envie
parce qu'on y croit parce qu'on sait que
faire ensemble c'est important ok bah
écoute et annick génial bravo c'est
gentil merci à écouter merci je pense
que vraiment ça donne envie de déjà
d'aller voir de participer activement le
s'inscrit donc c'est le samedi 11 mai
c'est de quelle heure à quelle heure eh
ben ça commence à 9 heures et puis on
finit tous par un défilé tous ensemble
et apparaît une remise de médailles
un peu dans le bazar mais c'est surtout
avec beaucoup de clubs venus avec est
sympa exactement
voilà bon encore bravo et encore merci à
très vite j'espère a même si yannick à
bientôt
[Musique]